what's up I never heed it unless you can
see I am not dead not only did Chadwick
Boseman play toala in Black Panther the
late actor also inspired some of the
most iconic lines and scenes following
Chadwick's tragic death from colon
cancer last week black panther director
Ryan cougler penned an emotional tribute
to the star revealing his influence on
the iconic film Ryan explained that
while he was watching the star film a
scene in Captain America civil war with
John Connie who played tala's dad he
learned that Chadwick had learned kosa
J's native language foreseen and that's
how it became the official language of
wakanda
quote the decision to have kosa be the
official language of wakanda was
solidified by Chad a native of South
Carolina because he was able to learn
his lines in kosa there on the spot the
director added that while he hadn't met
Chadwick at that point he was already in
awe of his capacity it as an
actor Ryan also added that Chadwick
advocated for his character to speak
with an African accent so that he could
present tala to audiences as an African
king whose dialect had not been
conquered by the
west and now present to you King
tala the
[Music]
Panther and remember that scene well
Chadwick's influence was all over it
Ryan revealed quote he said to me W
condens have to dance during the
coronations if they just stand there
with Spears what separates them from
Romans we go down forever
and it was Chadwick who inspired one of
the film's most famous lines delivered
by tala's cousin Eric kilmonger played
by Michael B Jordan in early drafts of
the script Eric killmonger's character
would ask tchala to be buried in wakanda
Chad challenged that and asked what if
kilmonger asked to be buried somewhere
else just bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the
ships cuz they knew death was better
than bondage yep that line was Chadwick
suggestion it's a beautiful thing in his
tribute Ryan said that he was also in
the dark about Chadwick's cancer
diagnosis which he had been battling
since 2016 quote Chad deeply valued his
privacy and I wasn't privy to the
details of his illness after his family
released their statement I realized that
he was living with his illness the
entire time I knew him because he was a
caretaker a leader and a man of Faith
dignity and pride he shielded his
collaborators from his suffering he
lived a beautiful life and he made great
art